It's my pleasure to welcome you to the third session of the New Drugs on
the Horizon series. This is the 22nd annual
of these series,
and this is put on by the Chemistry and Cancer Research Working Group.
Let's see, Start.
Let's see.
Okay, so just by way of reminders, the Chemistry and
Cancer Research Working Group has a couple of events coming up this evening.
First, at 5:15 to 6:00 PM, is the Outstanding
Achievement for Chemistry and Cancer Research Award lecture.
This year, the award has gone to Dr.
Cheryl Arrowsmith from the University of Toronto.
Shortly following that, there is a joint town hall session hosted by
the Chemistry and Cancer Research Working Group, as well as the Hematological
Malignancies Working Group. Promises to be a really exciting session
here on driving breakthroughs in blood cancer treatment.
Following that, there's a networking reception with alcohol, if
you're interested in attending.
Okay, so this year, for the first time ever, the Chemistry and Cancer Research
Working Group has established a development fund.
And the funds raised this year were used to support
travel awards for these eight very deserving young
investigators who are here at the AACR meeting
this year.
And so the CICR recognizes the importance of being able to attend
meetings like this early in one's career.
And we also appreciate the budgetary restrictions across much of the academic as
well as the industrial sector. And so the goal here was to do something to
help young people come to this meeting.
And so these investigators are here with us at the conference.
And so if you'd like to support this initiative for next year, we are
certainly very grateful for generous donations and
support, and you can use this QR code
to do so.
Okay, so the New Drugs on the Horizon series is a series that's sponsored by the
CICR.
This is really a flagship series that is known to be a
global stage for first disclosures.
Very exciting. This year, we've had 30 different nominations, and we're able to
select 12 speakers.
So here, this is revealing of chemical agents, biological
entities, revealing breakthrough biology, and really
shining a spotlight on next-generation therapeutics that are
poised to redefine the future of cancer treatment.
So without further ado, I'd like to introduce Dr.
Dan La to introduce our first speaker.
Can you hear me? Oh, okay.
So I'd like to introduce, it gives me great pleasure to introduce Marie
Evangelista.
She will be describing the platform that gave rise to
their clinical candidate,
targeting Cyclin AB RXL ligand pocket.
Good morning, everybody, and thank you to the organizers for giving me the
opportunity to speak to this group.
And also, I'm very privileged to be able to represent Circle Pharma.
I'm Marie Evangelista, and I'm the head of research.
So today, I'm going to be discussing
how we discovered CID-078, which is a
first-in-class oral macrocycle Cyclin AB RXL inhibitor
for the treatment of cancers with deficiency of
RB or hyperactivated E2F. Here are my
disclosures.
So macrocycles have enormous potential as therapeutics,
but they face important challenges that remain
as barriers in the field, even though they could potentially drug protein-protein
interactions, because they're not able to simply
achieve intracellular activity as well as oral
exposure. Many macrocycles are, in fact, limited to
extracellular targets and/or need
IV administration or rely on injectable
administration. So there's some very exciting macrocycles that have been
shown now to cross the cell membrane.
However, they're not absorbed in the gut, so they require usually IV
administration. There's examples of macrocycles that can target
extracellular proteins, and they can be administered orally,
but they often
depend on enabling formulations.
And so the secret or the holy grail in macrocycle drug
discovery is really to come up with macrocycles that are
oral and that can get into cells. And these are pretty
rare examples and often limited to novel
mechanisms. So at Circle, we have been building,
for many years, a platform that can unlock macrocycles, the
ability of macrocycles to penetrate cells and to have oral
exposure. We've been focused our macrocycle platform on
targeting the cyclins. The cyclins are the regulatory binding
partners of the CDK kinase inhibitors.
The CDK kinase inhibitors have been game-changing for
cancer therapy. The CDK4 inhibitors have especially been
really have been able to improve outcomes for patients with breast cancer.
However, the CDK4 and the 2 and the 4/6 base
has challenges. Many of these molecules are often cytostatic.
They have challenges in specificity and selectivity.
And there has been identified resistance mechanisms across these
different molecules, and the field's very
competitive. So in contrast, we have been focused
on targeting the hydrophobic patch in yellow of the cyclin, so
this is the opposite part of the cyclin CDK complex.
That hydrophobic patch is critically important for
mediating interactions between the substrates of the cyclins and
specific cyclins themselves.And so we have built a
pipeline, and today I'm going to talk
to you about our cyclin AB inhibitor, which is currently in phase one.
I think hopefully some of you were able to attend Ashwin Zullati's
talk yesterday, where he gave a talk at the plenary
session. We also have other cyclin
inhibitors. We're very excited about a cyclin D1 isoform
inhibitor that is poised to go into the clinic early 2027, and we
have efforts targeting the other cyclins.
So even though the hydrophobic patch is
very conserved amongst the different cyclins, we've been able to show
and make specific cyclin inhibitors, so A selective
dual AB, B selective and multicyclins.
And so how we position these depend on the biology of the
tumor. Our molecules, the
hydrophobic patch has not been shown to be drugged by
conventional small molecules, so we think
going after the hydrophobic patch offers a differentiated
mechanism. And also, our macrocycle platform
allows us to achieve exquisite selectivity over the cyclins
and other targets that we would not want to perturb,
which could result in a compelling safety profile.
So the hydrophobic patch and the ability to perturb
the interaction between proteins with RXL motifs
and this hydrophobic patch was inspired by the work from Bill Kaelin
back in 1999, where he showed by creating
these RXL cell-penetrant peptides, he could show specific
activity in cells that are high for E2F.
He also showed in this paper that normal cells, when
forced to activate E2F, are now exquisitely sensitive to these
RXL peptides compared to control
peptides. But even though this discovery had been made
many years ago,
which cyclins you needed to perturb was not
known. And then also, the mechanism of this
perturbation was unknown. And two,
companies that had been trying to drug this hydrophobic patch
had been unsuccessful. So the way we approach
macrocycles with our platform is really three-pronged.
I'm going to walk you through how we were able to do this for CID078, but you can
think about applying this to other protein-protein interactions
or other targets. So we start off with
a molecule
that could come from
literature or an RXL
peptide. We then are able to improve the properties and the
potency of such molecules through the application of
our macrocycle platform, which is essentially
based on semi-automated synthesis of
macrocycles using our solid phase chemistry, as well as
applying proprietary
machine learning models that are able to identify
and then predict properties that would
enable cell permeability as well as oral bioavailability.
And we've used modeling across the different cyclins and this hydrophobic
pocket to help us gain potency and selectivity for the different
cyclins.
So this slide represents many years of work
from our drug discovery team, and I'm going to show you some of the big
milestones that were achieved. But for those of you that are
interested in looking more into the details, there's a couple of papers that I
would draw your attention to. So we initially started with a
literature compound. This compound had some activity on the
cyclins, but was leveraging this arginine charge
motif here to gain the activity, which had now very big
impact on cell permeability. And so the first
step was really to remove that charged arginine and then gain
back some of the potency and then try to achieve some
permeability. So the team set out to
do this by leveraging hydrogen bonds as well as
hydrophobic interactions. And one of the very first hits they
identified was compound two, where this compound now
had some activity across the two different cyclins, and that was our
focus, a hint of cell permeability, and for the first time,
some cell activity. And so then the team began the
hit-to-lead work and focused on continuing
to reinforce that active confirmation through hydrophobic
interactions, increasing both permeability and potency, and
then starting to introduce some lipophilicity.
And so that resulted in a lead molecule, compound three.
So this molecule is cell penetrant, is highly active
and highly potent on cyclin A and B.
And for the first time, we were able to see potent cell activity.
We used this molecule to
show in vivo proof of concept that we could achieve tumor regression
in a model that had high E2F. However, as you can appreciate,
this molecule has really low percent F.
And so this molecule had to be administered through IP.
And so the final step was then to create a molecule
with drug-like properties. And so we continued to optimize
potency. We reduced some of the peptidic characters of the
molecule,
and continued to improve on the PK properties.
And so finally, this is CID078.
078 has exquisite sub-nanomolar potency on both cyclin A and
B. It is cell permeable. It has activity
in cells that are E2F high. And we have
moderate oral bioavailability,
improving from 2% to 25%.And
so we often get asked how you're able to obtain
selectivity over the other cyclins, given the hydrophobic patch is so
highly conserved amongst the different cyclins.
And so this is an example that I wanted to share with you where we can overlay
CID078 to the different cyclins. And here we're
overlaying it to cyclin A, B, and E.
And what I want to highlight in the boxed red are, even though
the binding mode for 078 is largely conserved between the
three different cyclins, it's these key residues that I've
outlined in red that are subtly different between the different
cyclins and impact the contact point of
how 078 binds to these different cyclins.
So the selectivity comes from the subtle differences in the
hydrophobic pocket and the ability of our macrocycle to make
multiple contacts. And that leads us
to have a molecule that's very potent on
A and B, but has
a selectivity profile over the other cyclins, in this case, cyclin E.
Okay, so these are the properties for CID078.
I'm not going to be able to go over all of the details of this, but what I
do want to highlight is that this macrocycle is large.
It's almost 1,000 molecular weight, and even though it
is large, we've been able to achieve and
balance drug-like properties. I also want to highlight that we
were able to show across multiple species in our preclinical work
that we had consistent oral bioavailability, and with this, we've been able
to predict what the human PK profile was, and that was shared
yesterday at the plenary talk.
Okay,
so I'm going to switch a little bit and talk about the mechanism of
action of CID078. The work of
understanding what AB inhibitors do in the context of E2F high
tumors was published using tool molecules last
year in a "Nature" paper. And I want to highlight the key authors on this
paper are the authors from Circle, Katie and Pablo,
who led this work in great collaboration with Matt
Osher, Deepak Nijhawan, John Dench, and
Benedikt Kessler.
So I'm going to start with just showing you what happens or what's
critically important in tumor cells as they go through the cell cycle.
So as many of you may
already know, the cyclin D and the cyclin E complexes really
regulate the inhibition of Rb.
Rb is a tumor suppressor that, in its
active form, binds E2F and keeps it off.
And it's really the job of these cyclins to now inhibit and phosphorylate
Rb to then release E2F. E2F in its
active form during the first part of the cell cycle can drive the
transcription of many, many target genes that are important for driving the
cell cycle forward. However, at the end of S
phase, in order to continue orderly cell cycle progression,
E2F must be turned off, and this is the job of the
cyclin A Cdk2 complex to then bind cyclin
E2F through its RXL motif and phosphorylate
and inactivate it. So our molecule
is a dual AB inhibitor. It binds cyclin
A and prevents the interaction from E2F, so the
activity of E2F is sustained at this important part of the cell
cycle. As a consequence, cells increase,
activate E2F target expression, and
as a consequence, undergo DNA damage,
experience DNA damage, as well as replication
stress. Our molecule also blocks the interaction of
cyclin B
and Mit1. Mit1 is an important critical
negative regulator of the cyclin B Cdk1 and cyclin B
Cdk2 complex, and so preventing this
interaction keeps that complex active.
And as a consequence, the
continued sustained activation of cyclin B Cdk1 forces
cells that have incurred replication stress and DNA damage into
mitosis prematurely. They activate phospho-separase, which
is a marker for us for target engagement of cyclin B, and
activate the spindle activation
pathway. And so it's really the combined action of both
inhibiting A and B together that leads
cells to undergo mitotic catastrophe as well as
apoptosis.
Okay, so the synthetic lethality mechanism that Bill
Kaelin described can also be described in this illustration
fromFrom Jeff Shapiro
whereby
E2F can be thought of as a threshold
that too much E2F could cause apoptosis in cells.
So in normal cells that have low levels of E2F or tumor
cells that have low
E2F, they can tolerate treatment with 078.
But cells that have particularly high E2F levels
when they're treated with the molecules continue to
elevate or activate E2F, and this
forces them to pass through this E2F apoptotic threshold, which we're
starting to call as a tipping point, and that results in
apoptosis and cell death. And so when we screen a large panel of
cancer cell lines, we find that cell lines,
gene set enrichment analysis shows that cell lines that are most sensitive to
078 express the
E2F target genes. And in fact, when we divide cell lines between
E2F high and low, it's the E2F high lines that are more sensitive to
CID078. Now I've talked about RB1 as a critical regulator
of E2F. RB1 loss or alterations
in RB1 increase E2F activity and, maybe
not surprising, cell lines that have alterations in RB are in fact
more sensitive to 078.
And in fact, if we look at biallelic inactivation or cell lines that
are heterozygous, it's the cell lines that have the biallelic inactivation
homozygous for RB that are most sensitive to
CID078. So as we think about translating this work into
the clinic, it'll be really important for us to annotate RB
accurately. And so most patients will come on our trial, and they'll be scored as
having an RB alteration. We'll really need to understand the type of
alteration. We'll also need to understand if both alleles are
inactivated, so biallelic inactivation.
But then we know that some tumors have
wild-type RB at the
sequence level, but when you look at the protein level loss, they have
loss of RB, likely through promoter methylation or other
events. So it's really for us to be able to understand RB deficiency in the
clinic, we're going to both integrate genomic
information as well
as protein information.
When we look across a number of solid tumors, we find that
perhaps up to 7% of tumors have the deficiency
of RB. And I'd like to highlight a couple of tumor
types, small cell lung cancer, which is really
where RB is the initial event and the driving
event in those types of tumors, as well as particular sarcomas,
leiomyosarcoma, where up to
almost 80 or 90% have RB loss.
And so here's an example from Inga Schaefer, who we've started to
collaborate with. She can show that cell lines that are deficient
for RB have loss of RB and are more sensitive to our
CID078 inhibitor. Here's an example from a small cell
lung model where
this tumor that is
lost for RB and has E2F high is very sensitive to our molecule.
And here's a
couple of examples in lung where, again, here's a model
that is E2F
high and altered for RB1, showing really nice
sensitivity to 078, and in contrast, a model that is
wild-type for RB and E2F low is less
sensitive to 078. So altogether, we've screened a
number of
PDX and CDX models, and we can see in some models, we see nice tumor
regression with 078, and this seems to correlate with
E2F expression as well as RB1 loss.
And what I do want to note on the bottom left there, even though
many of the tumors that are sensitive to 078 have loss of RB,
there are a number of tumors that have no evidence of RB1 loss.
So the ongoing work we're doing now with our team is to continue to
understand what are the drivers of E2F to inform
how we use CID078 in the clinic. So in
summary, CID078 is a first-in-class
orally macrocycle targeting a previously
undrugged part of the cyclins,
the cyclin AB complexes. The dual
inhibition of AB drives replication stress, mitotic
catastrophe, and leads to apoptosis in
cells. We see enriched activity in tumors that are E2F high or
RB loss, and we have a Phase I trial ongoing now.
So I want to thank the entire Circle 1 team. This was a big team effort.
I also wanted to thank the drug discovery in particular for bringing forward
CID078. I want to thank our collaborators over the
years. Not only am I excited about advancing such
molecules into the clinic, but because we have molecules that can selectively
inhibit the cyclins, we're learning and refining about what we know
about the cell cycle. So super excited to continue to work with
our collaborators on that front. And then lastly, I'd like to thank our
science advisors. Thank you.
Thanks for the great talk. The first question, what's the mechanism behind the
RSL peptide?
So the second question, so your molecule seems downstream of
CD4/6. It should work in CD4/6 inhibitor-resistant
model, right? So that's my two questions. Yeah.
Yeah. So I only heard the second question about the
post 4/6.
We would expect that patients' tumors that acquire
resistance to the 4/6 inhibitors that gain a
mutation or loss of RB could be sensitive to this
molecule, to this mechanism of action.
I'm sorry, I didn't quite hear the first question.
RSL peptideBecause you need a
structure. What's the mechanism behind the RSL peptide that
kills cancer
cells?
Oh, so the mechanism of action of how they kill cells?
Exactly, yeah.
And so this, I probably went very fast, and this has been described in our
"Nature" paper.
Yeah.
But it's about perturbing the interaction between E2F and cyclin
A, which further elevates or sustains E2F activity and
drives cells and incurs DNA damage.
But then it's also inhibition of the MYC1
interaction with cyclin B that forces cells
prematurely into mitosis, and as a consequence
of unresolved DNA damage, forces cells to
activate the activation spindle checkpoint pathway, and then ultimately
undergo apoptosis. So it's a pretty complex mechanism, but
really depends on both A and B
inhibition.
Thank you very much.
Over here. Yeah, excellent talk.
Many of the ADME and PK properties of these big
cyclic peptides, macrocycles,
depend on intramolecular hydrogen bonding
chameleonicity. I was just wondering with now your years of experience with this,
have you been able to model that and build that into the design of newer
generations?
Yes. Yes, we have in that we
critically rely on
the models that we've been able to build, and I also probably glossed over this,
but a lot of the work that our chemistry team did was really to improve the
hydrogen bonds, the interactions, as well as hydrophobic
contacts.
Hi. Rigo here from General Proximity.
My question's on the,
is it the MDCK Pampa? Wondering if there are any key
modifications, like incubation times or added
excipients to get a reliable data out of
that? And then a follow-up to this
is,
what are your recovery rates considering hydrophobic compounds
are probably going to be more attracted to than normal?
What are your typical recovery rates?
Yeah. I'm sorry, I'm not quite sure I understood your
question in terms of the recovery rates.
Considering it's a hydrophobic pocket,
I would imagine like
so
it might be lower recovery rates compared to
traditional properties, right?
For the permeability assays.
Yeah, so we've
been able to
in the permeability MDCK assays, the kind of values
that
we get are exceptional for our macrocycles.
I think a lot of this is because we've been able to
both
use the beyond rule of five, and so we maintain
discipline on the size of the macrocycle as well as the
rigidity of the conformation. So the recovery
rates are fine.
The other question was related to...
Key modifications. Do you use a certain concentration
or extended incubations, added excipients to
classical-
I don't believe we're doing anything fancy or special to-- Yeah.
Okay.
Yeah. And our chemistry lead is also here in the audience, so
I'd be happy to introduce you to him.
Yeah. So in the interest of time, last question here.
First of all, congratulations for excellent piece of work, and thank you.
So the question I have is,
would it be beneficial to also target cyclin E along
with A and B, or was it difficult to find that kind of a molecule?
Yeah. I think based on the biology team's work,
they realized it was important to have the selectivity
over E,
and so this was the focus of the Med Chem campaign.
With that said, I think going after the other cyclins, including D1 and
E, could be critically important.
And so some of that work is
ongoing now. But for the AB program, it was purposeful.
It was intended to be selective over E.
Thank you.
And we can talk about how the mechanism of action of E is
about shutting down E2F, whereas an AB mechanism would be about
exacerbating E2F. And so they would be doing opposite things.
Thank you. Please join me again in thanking Marie.
Okay, our next speaker will be Dr. Martin Pass from
Enfysta
Therapeutics, where he is the chief development officer.
Welcome, Martin.
I'd like to thank the organizers for the opportunity to talk to you today about
our clinical candidate, AMX883, which is an
oral degrader of BRD9 for the treatment of
AML. That's my disclosure slide.
I hardly need tell this audience that acute myeloid leukemia
is a highly aggressive disease with dismal outcomes.
And despite recent advances,
the median survival is still less than one year.
Now biologically, acute myeloid leukemia is characterized by a block
in the normal differentiation of myeloid precursors,
and that results in accumulation of highly proliferative
stem-like AML blasts.And whereas many
cytotoxic proliferative agents target these AML blasts,
there is an alternative approach which has gained ground in
recent years, and that's to target the block in differentiation
itself. So agents such as all-trans retinoic acid in acute
promyelocytic leukemia, the FLT3 inhibitors,
IDH inhibitors, and the many inhibitors targeting FLT3 mutations,
IDH mutations, and either NPM1 mutations or
KMT2A rearrangements respectively.
Notably, all of these agents target a subset of AML
characterized either by lineage or the presence or absence of
mutations. There isn't a broad-acting inducer of
differentiation.
Now, BRD9 is a bromodomain-containing
protein, and it is a unique component of
just one of the three BAF/SWI/SNF
chromatin remodeling complexes, namely non-canonical BAF.
BRD9 expression is elevated in AML,
and SMARCB1, which is a component of the other two BAF
complexes,
is downregulated in AML blasts, suggesting perhaps a greater dependence
on non-canonical BAF in AML blasts.
Now, what is known is a number of groups have shown that BRD9 and
non-canonical BAF maintain this differentiation block and
maintain the stemness of these myeloid precursors.
And targeting that BRD9 removes that
differentiation block and imparts a survival
advantage in models of AML and
induces morphological differentiation.
And for this reason, we chose to target BRD9 as a potential
broad-acting inducer of differentiation.
Now, the degraders which we've used to target this protein are slightly
different than the more familiar PROTACs that may be known to
you, which generally engage the E3 ligases
cereblon and VHL. Our compounds bind
only to the target protein initially,
in this case, BRD9. Only once bound to the target protein do they
engage the E3 ligase machinery. In this case, it's
DCAP16.
And once the ternary complex is formed,
the degrader forms
a covalent but reversible bond with the E3
ligase. This stabilizes the ternary complex,
allows the target to be ubiquitinated, and directed to
the proteasomal degradation machinery.
Our compounds have no or very little affinity for the E3
ligase in the absence of the target protein.
So the design of our libraries is modular.
We identify a selection of high-affinity binders to
the target protein, BRD9 in this case.
We have a whole variety of linkers
offering different vectors, different geometries, and different proteins,
different properties. And we have a range of
warheads offering, again, different properties and different geometries.
The warhead I'll talk about in the talk today is based on this
electrophilic warhead, the cyanoacrylamide, but we do have
other warheads that we employ. The library resulted after
some optimization in the compound shown in the middle there, which is already a
potent compound, a DC50 sub-nanomolar, and very
selective against related BRD proteins.
And we've shown that it does degrade by DCAP16.
The optimization of this molecule focused on increasing the speed of degradation,
which is something we found empirically to be important to elicit the biology,
optimizing the pharmacokinetics, and by that I mean really optimizing the
metabolism of the compound, all whilst maintaining the
selectivity. And this resulted in AMX883,
which is our clinical candidate,
a very potent compound. I'd just like to emphasize we're quoting the DC90 here,
the DC90 of 0.3 nanomolar. Very potent compound,
very selective against related proteins, orally bioavailable in every
species we tested it in. And very gratifying,
we were able to isolate this as a solid
form, a salt form, a solid form, crystalline, which we were able
to formulate for dosing in the clinic.
I've said much of this already. A very potent selective degrader, a very
fast degrader, and importantly for the disease
context, it degrades across a panel of AML
cell lines.
BRD9 is the only protein that AMX883
degrades, and the proteomics experiment on the left-hand side there,
the protein which looks like it might be
approaching significance is actually
MYB, M-Y-B, hematopoietic transcription factor.
We believe that's downstream of BRD9 degradation.
As evidence that the degradation is mediated by
the proteasome and the cullin-RING E3 ligase, we see
no degradation in the presence of the proteasome inhibitor bortezomib
or the neddylation inhibitor MLN4924.
As evidence that DCAP16 is the mechanism of action,
we see no degradation when we knock out DCAP16.
When we reintroduce DCAP16, we see degradation.
But when we reintroduce DCAP16 with a cysteine
mutation, cysteine 58 is mutated, we see no degradation,
suggesting that it is that cysteine that binds
to our cyanoacrylamide motif.
We were able to generate a cryo-EM structure of the
ternary complex of AMX883 bound to BRD9 and
DCAP16.
This confirms that it is indeed cysteine 58 which our compound
reacts with. But this also revealed
several-True glue-like interactions that
AMX883 is inducing in this ternary
complex.
Now, there's no single marker of differentiation,
so we use a panel of markers. Sorry, I'm a bit close to that.
A panel of markers to measure differentiation
across this panel of cell lines. I have to
say that this panel of markers is probably skewed to myeloid
differentiation. The first thing to note is that
AMX883 has broad activity across this cell panel,
but also you have to degrade this protein.
The inhibitor does not induce differentiation, so this is a
target that has to be degraded. And on the right-hand
side, we can show comparable degradation,
sorry, comparable differentiation induction
to the many inhibitors in cell lines which would be expected to be
sensitive to many inhibitors.
Now,
BRD9 and the non-canonical BAF are
involved in chromatin remodeling.
Of course, this involves
changing the accessibility of the chromatin and allowing transcription
of genes. So we ran a time course ATAC-seq experiment.
First thing to notice is that the initial changes are all about
loss of accessibility. And that loss of accessibility occurs
in
regions enriched for binding sites to hematopoietic
transcription factors, notably MIB, which I've already
mentioned, RUNX, CBP1, PU1.
That's followed in later time points by reduction of accessibility
to other hematopoietic transcription factor binding
sites. There is no initial increase,
gain of accessibility,
across any of these sites in the first six hours.
Related time points, we do see gain of accessibility through a number of these
hematopoietic transcription factors.
When you look at the transcript level, you
see
an induction of gene sets associated with myeloid
differentiation, a suppression of gene sets
associated with progenitors, and suppression of
Myc target gene sets.
So AMX883
induces rapid and prolonged degradation of
BRD9. On the left-hand side, we have a subcut tumor,
MV411-derived tumor, and you can see prolonged
degradation of the target, and that does outlast the pharmacokinetics of the
compound.
On the right-hand side, using a disseminated model
of MV411, using flow cytometry measure, we can
measure in the bone marrow, you can see induction of two markers of
differentiation there, CD11B, CD86.
We looked at efficacy in a number of models,
and just two of the patient-derived models are shown here.
In the Dana-Farber model on the left-hand side, we dosed the
animals for 40 days with either two different doses
and schedules of AMX883, venetoclax, or vehicle.
And you can see during the dosing period, we didn't lose any of the
animals treated with AMX883, whereas all of the animals
treated with venetoclax or vehicle lost condition and were lost to the
study.
In this model, we were able to measure tumor burden in either the
bone marrow or the blood. I'm showing data here from the bone marrow here, and you
can see complete suppression of tumor
growth, particularly at the 50 mgs
BID dose there, and this is at 21 days.
On the right-hand side, we've got another patient-derived xenograft, different
karyotype, different background mutational
status. Again, really profound
survival advantage.
Now, we believe that these inducers of differentiation are
going to have most clinical utility early on in the treatment
paradigm,
so in combination with standards of care in
AML. One of the most used standards of care in AML is
venetoclax. So in that regard, we wanted to
understand what role BRD9 and the non-canonical BAF may
have in the emergence of resistance to venetoclax.
This is a clinical
challenge. So what we did was culture
MV411 cells in increasing
concentrations of venetoclax over a two-month period.
At the end of that two-month period, we ran a dose response to venetoclax, and
that's the figure at the bottom in the middle.
And you can see that the cells that were cultured in venetoclax have
got a 500-fold less sensitive to
venetoclax than those cells cultured in the
vehicle medium.
We characterized those cells and showed that they are associated with
increases in MCL1 and increases in
BCL2, the target of venetoclax. Now, increases in MCL1,
of course, is a well-known clinical mechanism
of resistance to venetoclax.
If, instead of culturing with venetoclax alone, we cultured in the
presence of venetoclax and AMX883,
and this is the figure at the right-hand side at the bottom, we saw no
emergence of resistance to venetoclax, and we didn't see the increase
in the MCL1,
BCL2.Now,
we've combined
AMX883 with a whole range of agents which are used therapeutically
to treat AML,
and mostly we see additivity, but we do see synergy with
venetoclax. So we decided to take this into an in vivo model.
So this is an MV411 model. It's a disseminated model where we've got
bioluminescent tags on the MV411 so that we can image the
tumors in the animals.
And we treated them with venetoclax,
a somewhat suboptimal dose of AMX883 to
allow a window,
and the combination of the two, and I think you can see for yourself there that
we've really very effectively managed the tumor
burden
in these animals.
So in summary, AMX883 is a potent, highly
selective, orally bioavailable degrader of
BRD9,
acts via DCAF16, and induces differentiation across a
broad range of AML subtypes. We've seen
a significant survival advantage when we dose the compound in vivo
as a single agent, but we do see synergy in combination
with venetoclax. We've completed all our preclinical developments
of AMX883 now, and we anticipate this being in the
clinic in the second half of this year.
With that, I'll thank a fantastic group of
colleagues, past and present, at HamFista, some of who are in the
audience today. Our excellent collaborators at the Children's Cancer
Institute of Australia and at the
Dana-Farber, who have helped us generate some of
this in vivo data, but also for very helpful discussions
on this subject. And with that, I'll thank you for your attention.
Question here on the right.
Thanks for a great talk. So frankly, from WuXi AppTec. Big question.
BRD4 was BRD9, right? A lot of BRD4 has
been developed. So what's your expect BRD4 was BRD9?
So there's some different safety side you want to
solve. Why BRD9?
Well, we don't believe that BRD4 is involved in the
differentiation block that is specific to BRD9.
So that's why we want to target BRD9 specifically.
Okay. Thank you.
Center mic.
Really nice talk. I'm curious, I assume it's a reversible covalent, and do you
have to measure the washout rate? Is that significant to the
catalytic MOA having rapid decomplexation from
DCAF16?
Yes. It's very rapid. With some of the earlier compounds in this
series, we could detect conjugates, like
glutathione conjugates, with these compounds,
but
it really is very rapid. We can't
detect any of the ternary complex.
It was why we were quite surprised to see that we could actually
generate a cryo-EM
structure.
Thank you.
Over here on the right.
Very nice talk.
So you have impressive subnanomolar activity with the compound,
and yet when
you present the animal studies, the doses are fairly high, meaning
100 milligrams per kilogram.
Yeah.
So I was wondering if you have any data you could share in
terms of the concentrations
resulting from these doses because, and I've seen this with other programs,
you have these unbelievable subnanomolar compounds,
but if the doses generate, say, micromolar
concentrations,
what's the benefit when it comes to-
Yeah
... efficacy versus toxicity?
So the doses that we require to see efficacy in mouse
models are determined by mouse PK.
This is a high clearance compound in mouse PK.
In terms of the concentrations required to see efficacy,
we find that we need free concentrations exceeding the
DC90, so it's nanomolar. We need nanomolar
concentrations of this to see efficacy.
Thank you.
Great talk. Thank you.
My question was,
do you see an effect on the normal healthy PBMCs for
your BRD9 degradation? Does that induce immunosuppression in your mouse
models?
We don't have great cross-reactivity
with
the mouse, so I'm not sure we'd see it there.
But we've completed tox studies on this, and that is not something we've
seen in higher animals as well. It's a
theoretical possibility because noncanonical BAF is
involved in normal hematopoiesis, but we think there might be a
margin there by the virtue of BRD9 being overexpressed
and SMARTB1, which is in the other two BAF complexes,
being downregulated. So we think there might be a margin
between blasts and normal healthy
cells.
Thank you.
Can I ask one question as well?
Yeah.
Can you comment on if you've looked at heart PD,
BRD9 degradation in the heart, and also your expectations for safety?
Yeah. So I think you probably are alluding to
some observations. So for context here, two PROTACs,
BRD9 PROTACs did enter the clinic targeting synovial
sarcoma, and there was some observations of QT
prolongation there.
And of course, we don't know whether that's down to BRD9 degradation or the fact
that they were both PROTACs. We don't know.
For our part, we have-been very
thorough in terms of characterizing the potential safety of
this. So we've gone above and beyond.
We've done work in human cardiac myocytes, we've done work
in telemetered animals in vivo to understand.
And we can't see, at least pre-clinically, we cannot see
any QT liability for this compound.
Of course, we have to test it in the clinic to be timely for real.
Okay, please join me in thanking Martin for a fantastic talk.
Okay, our next speaker is Smruthi Vijayaraghavan
from J&J. She's director and head of Solid Tumor Oncology
Discovery.
And today she'll be talking about the ENPP targeted ADC leveraging the
auristatin platform.
Thank you. And thank you to the organizers for this
opportunity to present our pre-clinical work on our
novel ENPP3 targeted ADC in solid tumors.
So these are my disclosures.
So I wanted to start with a little bit background on the target.
So ENPP3 or ectonucleotide
pyrophosphatase/phosphodiesterase is a type II transmembrane
protein, and it's part of the cell surface ENPP family.
In terms of its expression, ENPP3 has an apically
restricted expression in most normal tissues,
and this provides a unique opportunity being less
accessible to systemic circulation.
However, in tumors it is depolarized, making it more
readily accessible to antibody-based therapeutics, and thus
creates a more tumor-selective targeted opportunity.
In addition to this difference in polarity, we also see elevated
expression in several solid tumors of high unmet need.
In terms of its function in normal tissues, ENPP3
is known to hydrolyze extracellular
pyrophosphatase/phosphodiesterase bonds and is also
predicted to be a basophil activation marker.
However, in tumors its role is really not well understood.
So one of the first things to better understand the expression of ENPP3,
we developed an immunohistochemistry or an IHC assay, and
here looked at a panel of solid tumors.
And as you can see on the graph on the left, we see broad and
high ENPP3 expression across several solid tumors,
including about 93% of clear cell renal cell carcinoma,
78% of papillary renal cell carcinoma, and around
45% to 50% in several solid tumors,
including colorectal, lung adenocarcinoma, as well as
endometrioid cancers.
In addition to the high prevalence, the graphs on the right here
also show that in the top three tumor types that are showing
here, in addition to the high prevalence, we also see high percent
positivity within these tumors. So I think this
data really makes this a novel and attractive
target for us to go after in several of these solid tumors
of interest. And what I'm going to be talking about today is
obviously our novel ENPP3 targeted
ADC, and how we leverage this biology and expression to
develop this asset.
So before I get into the molecular design, just a little bit background on
ADCs. I'm sure almost everyone here is aware that
antibody-drug conjugates work based on binding of
an antibody to a tumor-specific antigen.
This results in internalization of the antibody, intracellular
payload release, which in turn causes tumor cell killing.
Over the last few years, ADCs have become a clinically validated
modality in solid tumors. While that's quite exciting,
one of the high unmet needs and the challenge still remains being
able to find novel and clean targets within the solid
tumor space. And I think that's where we have an advantage here
with ENPP3, both leveraging the high levels of expression
or prevalence as well as the apical restriction.
So in terms of the actual molecular design, obviously one of the first
key components here is our antibody.
So through extensive screening, we identified our lead
antibody binder, which is a high-affinity ENPP3
specific binder, and it's bivalent to ENPP3 with
no off-target
binding.
It shows rapid internalization as well as favorable
biophysics, looking at stability, aggregation, and also
manufacturability.
So the second key component for the ADCs are
obviously the linker payload platform.
And for this, we leveraged the dolastatin
platform, which we actually licensed from Mersana Therapeutics,
now part of Day One Pharma.
And one of the key components of this platform is actually the
unique and novel auristatin-derived payload
called the AFHPA.
As you can see in the cartoon there at the bottom,
AFHPA by itself is cell permeable and can cause
bystander effect. However, within the tumor cells, it
undergoes a metabolism where it cleaves off the
HPA component, resulting in an auristatin F or an
AF payload, and this does not have any bystander
effect. So this actually results in a controlled
bystander effect with our molecule.
In terms of the conjugation, we have a site-specific
conjugation with a branch linker that allows us to get
a consistent molecular profile with a high stable and a
uniform DAR.
And in terms of biophysics, our ADC shows a favorable
biophysical profile as well as stability and
supports further development.So this, kind of the
two key components that I described here, gets us to our
actual lead molecule, which is our novel ENPP3-targeted
ADC, JNJ-89862175, or
JNJ-2175, as I'll call it hereafter.
So in the next part, we're obviously sharing some of the preclinical
characterization that we did with this molecule.
So the first thing we looked at is we looked at binding.
And as you can see there, we see potent
dose-dependent binding of JNJ-2175 on
ENPP3 positive cells, but no binding on
ENPP3 negative cells. In addition, we also see
no binding on ENPP1 and
ENPP2 positive cell lines. So this confirms
the specificity of JNJ-2175.
The next thing we looked at is internalization, which, as
I said, is one of the key components of an ADC.
And here we performed a confocal live
imaging on a panel of ENPP3 positive and
negative cell lines. And the images that I'm showing here are on two
positive cell lines with varying expression levels of
ENPP3. And as you can see there,
JNJ-2175, shown in the yellow dots, show
potent internalization on both the cell lines.
The quantification there at the bottom is the time course, and it
shows that we do see rapid internalization with our
molecule.
So with these components, the next thing we wanted to look at was the in
vitro potency of our molecule. And here we are looking
at cytotoxicity on a panel of ENPP3 positive cell
lines with varying expression levels of ENPP3,
as well as an ENPP3 knockout or a negative cell line.
And we see that JNJ-2175
demonstrates a potent dose-dependent cytotoxicity
on all of the positive cell lines,
when compared to the isotype control ADC.
However, no cytotoxicity was seen in the
ENPP3 negative cell line.
In addition to the direct killing that we're seeing here, we also looked
at bystander activity, which as I previously described, is one of
the key components with this platform.
So to do this, we actually mixed or co-cultured
an ENPP3 positive cell line, shown here in red
fluorescence at the bottom, with an ENPP3 negative cell
line that is shown in green fluorescence.
And what we saw here is we did see,
over time, a time course which is shown at the top, a
potent killing of the ENPP3 negative cell line in the
presence of JNJ-2175, only when they are
co-cultured with the ENPP3 positive cell line.
And as a control in this assay, we also ran our
ENPP3 antibody that was conjugated with MMAF, which
as we all know, does not have any bystander effect.
And as you can see on the graph on the top, we didn't see any
killing of the ENPP3 negative cell line.
So this confirms that we both have potent direct killing, but
also bystander activity with our molecule.
And finally, we looked at the in vivo efficacy of our
molecule on a panel of both cell line-derived and
patient-derived xenograft models.
And here I'm showing three different PDX models
from both non-small cell lung cancer as well as RCC,
with a range of ENPP3 expression. And as you can
see across all three models, we see a dose-dependent
anti-tumor efficacy with JNJ-2175,
with complete regressions observed in all three models.
So this kind of confirms the activity of our molecule
pre-clinically in vivo as well.
So with that, in summary, I showed you how
ENPP3 is a novel target with broad
expression in several solid tumors, and also having epically
restricted expression in normal tissues.
In terms of the actual molecule, our lead molecule,
JNJ-2175, has a high-affinity ENPP3
specific bivalent antibody that is site-specifically
conjugated to a novel MTI-based payload, which
shows controlled by standard activity.
And in terms of the key pre-clinical characterization,
we observed favorable biophysics and developability profile,
and I showed you data that shows we have potent in vitro
ENPP3 specific binding, rapid
internalization, cytotoxic activity in vitro along
with bystander activity, as well as a robust anti-tumor efficacy
in vivo.
Finally, we've also completed our IND-enabling non-human
primate studies, and we see that the molecule is tolerated
in non-human primate studies, as well as demonstrated a
favorable pharmacokinetic profile.
So currently, our molecule is in Phase 1 dose-escalation
study.
So with that, I'd like to thank everyone who's been part
of this great team, and also thanks to our collaborators
at Mirsana or Day One. And finally, a special thanks to all the
patients and families who are part of the clinical trial.
And of course, thanks everyone for your attention. Be happy to take any questions.
Looks like we have one question here in the center.
Sorry.
Thank you for this excellent talk.
Really interesting.Empp3 has been
pursued a few times, and one of the
issues that's bedeviled Empp3 ADCs has been
the heme tox, likely due to the basophil binding.
I note that your molecule is Fc silent.
Wondering if that was a deliberate decision to
mitigate the heme risk, and whether you have any evidence about
heme toxicity or basophil interaction with your molecule in your
preclinical studies.
Yeah, no, good question.
Thank you. I can't directly comment on the role of the Fc
silent versus Fc active and how that may or may not
mitigate heme tox. Of course, in our preclinical
non-human primate studies, we did not see any
tox that we think would be a limitation.
And I think in terms of previous molecules, again, it's hard to comment because
there are a lot of differences in terms of the linker payload
as well as the antibody, like you pointed out, between ours and their
molecules. So I think it would be hard to make that direct comparison.
Thank you.
Sure. Thanks.
Hi. I was wondering
from the perspective of the radioligand therapies kind of coming in wave, and
I see Novartis is getting a foothold here in San Diego.
What would be, in your opinion, a criteria to determine a
program would be better suited for radioligand therapy development
versus ADC, considering maybe one can get a macrocyclic peptide
for a target like this. What would be
that decision maker in terms of criteria to
decide one versus the other?
Yeah, I think that's hard. I don't think I can really comment on that.
Yeah.
Smruthi, I have a quick question.
I noticed in your RCC PDX model the graph all the way
to the right, it took till about day 28 to start seeing an
effect, and
there was really no dose response.
It seemed like
there was this hysteresis almost. Is that explainable?
Is that a tumor penetration, or is it a mechanistic-
It-
... reason as to why it takes so long?
It's a good question, and honestly, something that we have wondered as well,
because we do see differences even as you saw in the data between the
different models, and I think it could be a
combination of things, including payload sensitivity, growth
kinetics of the model as well. But I don't think...
Yeah, we don't have any data to directly point to one direction or the other.
Okay. Thank you.
I have a quick question. So, very
nice summary about this new ADC. So
from the payload
selection perspective, so what make you
select this microtubule inhibitor rather
than Topo, the well-established class in
this ADC development?
No, that's a good question, and I think it was more the
combination of what we saw in terms of expression and the biology of
the target, as well as the novelty of the platform, as I
described, that made us think that these would be good pairings.
And obviously, when we put it together, we see really good potency,
efficacy, but also tolerability, I think, which gave us
confidence that this is something that we'd want to continue developing in the
clinic.
Another follow-up. So for this, it is your own
payload, which is different from the MMAE and/or
MMAF, right? So when you design this new payload,
what is your consideration?
Unfortunately, I can't really comment on that because we did license
the dolasentin platform from Mersana on day one, so
we did not directly design it. So yeah, and I
believe they do have publications and presentations around this
particular platform.
Great. Thank you.
Sure.
Okay, please join me in thanking Smruthi.
Thank you.
Okay. That brings us to our final speaker for this session,
Dr. Stefan Pleiss,
who is Senior Director and Head of Translational Science Leads in
Oncology within the Early Development at Ipsen
Biopharmaceuticals. Welcome, Stefan.
Yes, hello. Good morning, everybody.
Thank you to the organizers, thank you to CRCR to give us the opportunity to
present.
Today, we introduce IPN-1203, a dual T cell agonist
activating Vbeta6 and Vbeta10 TCR expressing T
cells.
These are our disclosures. This work is
a collaboration between Ipsen and Marengo Therapeutics, and the design and
conduct of these non-clinical studies were conducted by
Marengo.
And
so we believe next generation T cell activators are really necessary
to overcome some limitations of cancer immunotherapy.
Despite their success, though, current immunotherapies really
remain limited. They show poor control of which T cells are
activated and how strong and for how long.
Many current approaches depend on pre-existing
tumor-infiltrating lymphocytes, but very often these
populations are dysfunctional and exhausted.
Tumor antigen
dependence looks for higher density and
homogeneity, and that's also sometimes difficult to find in solid tumors.
There is also, with regard to overall T cell
activation,
the impact of cytokine release and toxicity, which limits dose
density and
the therapeutic window.And finally, these
therapies also don't often establish
a memory skewed
development, and so durability of the response is also
limited.
So next generation T cell activators really address some of
these limitations, and you get activation that is selective,
controlled, and durable.
These bispecific T cell activators really
solve four issues at once.
They allow expansion of select subsets of T cells.
They do it in an antigen-agnostic manner.
And because they
select a subset of T cells, they potentially improve the
therapeutic window. And because you can also
employ cytokine tuning, this helps you
with
developing a durable
CD8-based activation and persistence of those
cells.
So a critical insight is that you
don't actually need to engage 100% of your T cell repertoire.
You could
get a very selective engagement through, for example,
binding to V alpha or V beta domains of the TCR, and that,
in the case of V beta, for example, really selects a smaller
but gets very coherent T cell
subsets
and
work for V beta domains at King's College.
And Merango Therapeutics also has demonstrated that this
interaction is very distinct from what you see
with CD3 engagement, for example.
So you see a much more productive activation, you see a reduction of
your exhaustive T cells, and you see a
restoration and invigoration of your
functional tumor-invasive infiltrating lymphocyte pool.
So IPN 1203 was really designed to put
these principles into practice.
So with regard to the molecular design, how do you do selective
activation? So IPN 1203 is a bispecific
Vbeta6 and Vbeta10 selective T cell
activator with an IL-15 receptor co-activation built in.
The design is based on Merango Therapeutics' STAR platform.
STAR stands for Selective T Cell Activation Repertoire.
And because you activate Vbeta6 and Vbeta10 T
cells, this really actually represents around 11% of
your tumor-infiltrating lymphocytes in tumors based on an analysis by
Tempus. And so this is a meaningful but
restricted T cell subset.
So one arm of
IPN 1203 was actually optimized to bind the
6-5 Vbeta domain of TCRs, and because of
cross-reactivities, binds really a range of Vbeta6
and Vbeta10 members in T cells with
these types of TCRs. So really
selectively engaging a defined T cell subset.
And as noted already, the mode of activation is mechanistically
distinct from CD3 engagement, resulting in a
very different quality of T cell activation.
And the second component on the,
I can actually do that, on the right-hand side is the
wild type IL-15
that's presented here together with the IL-15 receptor alpha sushi domain,
so resulting in a high-affinity cytokine co-signal
that enhances cytotoxic function and supports
survival, memory formation, and persistence of T
cells.
And this IL-15 configuration, of course, it's sort of a superagonist concept,
and it has clinical validation.
Of note, the Vbeta binding arm is also used in
Merango's STAR-602 compound in Vicafusbi alpha, which is
already in the clinic.
And the high affinity interaction with the 6-5
encoded Vbeta domain
is approximately 1.9 nanomolar.
And finally, we use an in-format control
molecule, which we call RSV IL-15, the same overall
configuration, but binding to an unrelated RSV
antigen, so therefore not engaging with the TCR.
And because of this format, it is a three-chain
construct, and here are the sequence.
Okay. And we describe the pharmacological properties now in the
following slides.
So very straightforward mechanistic evaluation.
How does IPN 1203 perform in short-term
binding and activation assays?
So on the
left-hand side, you see potent binding of IPN 1203 to
CD8 and CD4 conventional T cells, and the
level of engagement in PBMCs of healthy volunteers
reflects pretty much the prevalence of Vbeta6 and
Vbeta
TCR T cell populations around 6%.
We don't see binding to B cells or monocytes, minimal at
least, and both IPN 1203 and RSV IL-15 as
a comparator because the IL-15 component binds actually
strongly to natural killer cells.
And we will come back to that, what it means for in vivo situations at a
later slide.And on the right-hand side then,
you see how this binding is associated with signaling.
And so we measure rapid and robust activation, in this case for
IL-15 receptor signaling to STAT5, similar to the
IL-15 control compounds. Here was RSFV, IL-15, and
recombinant human IL-15. And now the signal here comes up at 10
minutes already. And as you see, the TCR engagement
itself
does not induce a STAT phosphorylation.
And in other readouts not shown here, we also see rapid and robust
engagement of proximal TCR signaling components,
SLP76 and ERC. And overall, this demonstrates a
receptor engagement of the two binding moieties within
IPN-1203.
Okay. So from a short exposure to a longer
exposure, so what happens when we expose these T cells, let's say,
for five days, which is a very standard length of treatment?
And here on the left side, we look at activation of T cells
after five days in in vitro PBMC cultures, and you see very
preferential activation of Vbeta positive
T cells, so T cells that have Vbeta6 and Vbeta10
epitopes.
And the activation is measured through CD25 upregulation,
which is an EC50 of about 50 picomolar,
and it is much, much higher than the more moderate signals that we see for
all the other Vbeta T cells in culture.
And the RSV control arms are indistinguishable between
these two different populations, reflecting the
non-selective
manner of interaction.
And
on the right, after TCR seq analysis,
now also another look at the selectivity.
At baseline, Vbeta6 and Vbeta10 sequences constitute about
13% of the measured pools. And after IPN-1203
exposure, this has markedly increased to around
60%.
And the Vbeta6-5 T cells expand the
most, reflecting the high affinity interaction that I had mentioned
previously. So as you can see, this is a strong and target
restricted expansion, not a subtle repertoire shift.
So
what phenotype
do these cells expand to
acquire? So on the left, we revisit proliferation events.
We are showing you day five readouts and, again, the CellTrace
Violet dye dilution. We see robust and preferential activation of the
Vbeta positive T cells with that TCR
and compared to the Vbeta negative T cells.
And the activation and proliferation is also stronger for CD8 cells compared to
CD4 cells.
And when we're looking at the memory phenotype, here this central memory for
CD95 positive, CD27 and CDR7 positive T cells,
we see that there's an imprinting towards a central memory-like phenotype
associated with persistence.
So
we also see a very robust interferon gamma signal from our cytokines
together with really moderate and controlled induction for other
pro-inflammatory cytokines. But let's move to in vivo.
So in mouse,
we don't have
TRBV6 homolog, so we have to work with a surrogate.
We're using a surrogate that targets Vbeta13 and the IL-15
receptor sig. And obviously, we check binding affinities
and relevant outputs in spleen,
murine splenocytes.
And in a mouse model here in CD26 tumor,
we see that IPN-1203 surrogate drives potent tumor growth
inhibition and improves survival.
We see complete responders, in this case, 4 out of 10 mice
with a dosing of one in three mg per kilogram weekly dosing.
And when we look at the mechanism by depletion of specific T cell
subsets, we see that the efficacy is dependent on CD8
T cells, and it's also dependent on TCR
Vbeta13 T cells. The efficacy goes away when you deplete
these sets.
And
on the right,
oh, yeah, here. So we see that we also
see a very
increase in the total CDR3 count after TCR seq analysis,
specifically for TRBV13-2 and
TRBV13-3 sequences. So
exactly the sequences that would be engaged
through the Vbeta13 surrogate.
We see also durable regressions and
complete responses with the B16F10 models.
And when we challenge these complete responders
at day 100,
we don't see actually further tumor outgrowth, so really consistent with a
durable immune memory.
And looking deeper into these tumors, when we do single cell RNA
seq analysis and, on the left-hand side, look at
the composition of our tumor-infiltrating lymphocytes, we see a
marked reduction in our exhausted cell population, more than
50%, and a shift towards central memory and effector
memory CD8 cells, in this case, an increase of
almost fivefold.
And
when we look now at transcription factors
within these tumor-infiltrating lymphocytes, we
see also a very characteristic pattern.And
that happens globally across a range of different T
cell populations that IPN 1203 drives the
upregulation of a very coherent memory plasticity
and TCR coupled transcriptional program, while
exhaustion
associated regulators such as Tox or NF4A2
are very strongly suppressed.
Now with RSVIL 15, you only get down-modulation of
transcriptional factors, but in both instances, 1203
surrogate and RSVIL 15, you see that
there's a clear exhaustion avoidance signal.
So this highlights also, again, a pronounced distinction between
cytokine-only signaling and TCR anchored
activation.
So finally, in the monkey,
we see
target mediated drug deposition, TMD DPK profile here on the left.
And the impact of that is shown here on the right on Vbeta6 positive
T cells, where we see again an initial margination after dose
administration. And then we see a sustained and durable
dose-dependent expansion of these T cells,
with extended elevated tail,
for the Vbeta6 population dosed at 0.25 mg per kilogram.
This is an upregulation in absolute numbers of
19-fold, whereas those Vbeta negative T cells only expand about
3.6-fold. And here at the end,
that actually represents still an upregulation of three-fold above
baseline.
We do not see
expansion of natural killer cells.
So despite IL15 engagement,
we see in other systems an expansion of NK cells
with the RSVIL 15 comparators solely,
in vitro and in mice, but we do not observe NK expansion in
the presence of T cell activation and expansion.
And the bullet points here also summarize some safety relevant aspects, a
minimal cytokine release in the monkey, really no specific TBEC cell
expansion, and overall an acceptable safety profile
aligned with the mechanism of action.
So in conclusion, IPN 1203 is a potent next
generation T cell activator.
It drives strong selective Vbeta6 and Vbeta10 specific T cell
expansion with durable central memory imprinting.
It demonstrates complete tumor regressions, long-lasting immune
memory, and a transcriptional rewiring of our two main filtration
lymphocyte pools,
and also shows a clean tolerability profile, targeted
activation, minimal cytokine release, and this really is a
compelling rationale for ongoing clinical evaluations.
We are now in phase one.
Those expansion trials and the first patients have been dosed.
So with that, I want to thank our colleagues at Merango Therapeutics for their
incredible effort over the last four to five years.
I also want to thank my Ipsen colleagues for their help in preparation of
this presentation. And I thank you for your attention.
I see we have a question over here on the left.
Yes. Thanks for the great talk. Very interesting.
So what's your rationale of select V6, V10,
Vbeta6, Vbeta10? Because AstraZeneca
present data very similar like yours, but is Vbeta
non-selective. And so that's my question number
one. Question number two is
you showed the CD4 CD8 binding, but no
function. So because AstraZeneca data show like their
antibody Vbeta non-selective TCE, show
like only induce half of CD8
or half of CD4, basically. Like CD8,
like cellular production is twice of CD4.
So any data from your study or?
Well, I think you make an excellent point.
These are very different strategies to get a very subset selective
activation of T cells or subset selective
engagement of T cell.
And here with our T cell activators, we actually really have a very different
activation profile.
You're correct in that the assignment of
cytokine release to CD4 cells have been demonstrated in many
different settings.
Here we have a reduced activation of CD4 cells, and actually
our cytokine profiles, when we compare to what is in the literature,
I want to point out, we're looking at five-day
supernatant values very often, whereas in the literature, you very often find
24 or 48 hours.
Our levels are very often below what is published.
So,
the
important aspect, I think, in the clinical setting is that we will
have to focus absolutely on patient safety and evaluate
the outcomes of the treatments in these patients and really learn
from these effects.
Yeah. So my question's because more safety and
also because you have all the good things, increased proliferation,
decreased exhausting marker, and all.
But,
so
why beta six and beta 10?
So, do you profile all the different Vbeta?
Yeah, there's no binding to other Vbeta subpopulations.
And this was published actually by Merango, in publications in
2023.
King's College, London, also, talked very specifically about the
Vbeta engagement.
Okay. Thank you.
Happy to add, CEO of Merango, Zhen Xu.
So the Vbeta six and 10's at the highest prevalent in the TL
compartments. So if you look at it, actually have a very broad, a quarter
of tumor antigens covered by the Vbeta six, 10 population,
and preferentially CD8. So we do-
Can you please repeat your question?
You're notWe cannot hear you
either.
Can you?
I think it's the center mic. Are you addressing the question?
Yeah, great. So the question, just hoping that to answer that question that why
Vbeta 6 and 10 is the TIL prevalence and CD8 bias
in terms of the activation. And also you don't have
autoreactive clones in that subpopulation.
If I understand you correctly, you're wondering about the engagement preferentially
for CD8 versus CD4.
So the density of the particular
IL-2 beta receptor is very different between NK cell,
CD8 cells, and CD4 cells. And so this is one of the main key drivers
to
modulate interactions with those different T cell pools.
Yeah.
Okay. In the interest of time,
please join me in thanking Stefan. Thank you so much for a lovely talk.
And we have a few concluding remarks
to close out the New Drugs on the Horizon three-part series.
Okay. As we close out the New Drugs on the Horizon, the 2026
version,
I'd like to thank Raquel Castellanos for putting together this
slide. She is the AACR director of the
CICR.
And I'm struck by when I see this slide, the chemical
diversity
that ranges from biologics that weigh over
100 kilodaltons down to molecules that are below 500 molecular
weight. This really captures the creativity that this community
brings to address maladies that are
very serious and need very creative solutions.
So I think on behalf of Kate and myself,
the CICR, which is chaired by Danet Daniels,
as well as the AACR, we'd like to thank the speakers today as well
as all the speakers from part one and two as well.
But mostly we'd like to thank you for your participation, your kind
attention, and all the work that you do to generate this